I have a book in my bag and on that book
I draw all sorts of layouts all the time
that's how I design websites it start
but a piece of paper and I just draw
some stuff and I go haha this would be
super cool so a couple of years ago I
made this design and when you look at it
you go yeah this looks like a standard
web design it's fairly basic it has some
interesting stuff like there's the
categories and title at the top and then
you have the featured image and then you
have the meta content on the left hand
side or right hand side right hand side
and then the content itself and you go
yes sure this is relatively easy to do
except on smaller screens I wanted to
make a slight change move the meta
content from next to the content up
above featured image and then on even
smaller screens I want to move the
featured image of above rest of the
content and at this point you go this is
not so easy you see any one of these
three on their own is a piece of cake
combined on one website with just CSS
and HTML impossible because you'd have
to change the mark-up structure to get
this to work with old layout tools so
instead you'd have to go with JavaScript
and have to change everything which is
not great because then you're changing
everything and it shouldn't be like that
today I want to talk to you about a
whole new way of thinking about layouts
on the web and this whole new way of
thinking about layouts will truly change
the way we design websites from here on
forward I'm not talking about emerging
technologies that are coming two or
three years from now I'm talking about
technologies are here today that you
need to start using today it's called
CSS grid I'm working on Hendrickson and
let's get cracking so just to prove to
you that I'm not making things up this
is the layout I drew built purely in
HTML and CSS and WordPress running in a
browser today and all the stuff that you
saw
it's happening plus a bunch of other
things this website you're seeing here
is my website so if you go to Morton com
grab the side of your browser and start
doing this you'll actually see the
content jumping around on the page and
your brain will say there's some
JavaScript happening here or this might
be bootstrap it's not it's just pure
simple CSS and in fact the HTML behind
it is cleaner than any HTML you'll ever
see from WordPress before this point so
instead of going through the entire
WordPress thing which will take way too
long I decided to make a slightly
simpler example so I made this little
web page for the room we're in so this
is the speaker track for today and when
you look at it I want you to think about
how you would make this layout using
only HTML and CSS no frameworks nothing
else just look at it for one second I
think how would I mark this up all right
it's here so first you're probably going
to do something like draw boxes around
the main item so here we have some sort
of header saying and then there's a huge
section on the side but all the content
and then on the other side there's like
a logo and then there's some other
sidebar stuff good so we have those
boxes and we'll mark that up in HTML
then because we have to lay this out we
need to start grouping elements so below
the main header saying there's a bunch
of content but the content is displayed
in two columns so we need to put a box
around them so we can float them left to
right or you select to put them left and
right then in the sidebar we have
another grouping of contents and since
we're floating that we need to put a box
around that and then inside the cyber
itself there's two more pieces of
content the need box to surround them so
we end up with something like this the
blue sections are semantic markup things
that are required for the document to
work this is the actual content the red
sections are boxes that we drew around
content solely to say this is a thing
that will go next to another saying and
this is another thing that will go next
to another thing and you
see that the markup is full of that
stuff when you start looking at
responsive layout that gets super
complicated because in this responsive
layout you see that that's saying the
black box that's on the sidebar that's
actually the header and this the small
box on the far right-hand side that has
some address information that's actually
the footer and on a mobile display the
semantic structure is as it should be on
the other end of the scale everything
has been moved around and then you say I
can do this
bootstrap is my friend everything is
fine
the problem is what bootstrap does to
fix this and all the other frameworks is
take the HTML and apply some JavaScript
and move the HTML around in the document
to get this stuff to work that means for
accessibility reasons the whole document
is now jumbled which is not great it
also means we're leaning on external
technologies to do something that should
work on its own the problem is web
layouts the way we've been doing it
since the beginning of web time have
always been broken and all we've been
doing this entire time is refine how we
break the layout so we start with tables
then we had frames then we had layers
then we had slopes and clears then we
had flexbox and all this stuff is trying
to solve this fundamental problem which
is a web document so hTML is a document
that starts at the top and ends at the
bottom and anytime you want to put
something next to something else you
have to somehow break the document just
to do that which goes against everything
we want to do in design consider this
super simple example you have a box and
then two boxes inside two column layout
simple right should be well if you look
at just the markup this is what you get
just two boxes below each other with a
box around them then you have to put
them next to one another so you use
float few floats one item to the left
and the other one item to the right and
then the box that surrounds the
collapses
of course you're floating content so
you're pulling them out of the structure
of the document and then you want
content to float around it to fix that
you then have to introduce a clear fix
so that's just empty content that you
stuff on the bottom corner solely for
the purpose of making that box wrap
around those contents again and then you
say well we have better tools now we
have flex box and it's true flex box
does solve this problem but if I make it
just one element more complicated flex
flex doesn't help us any more because
now we can't say to flex put the content
through other pieces next to another
than one piece not flex box would try to
treat all three as the same thing
because flex box works in one direction
either horizontal or vertical so now we
have to introduce an extra box and say
can you please flex this container thing
next to the other thing and then inside
the container we'll put two things
underneath one another this is the hack
this is not the way it supposed to be
this is truly a hack this is how we
design websites today we cheat we build
a bunch of extra stuff just to get our
layouts to work it's nuts if you think
about it it's totally crazy slowed and
flex forced us to put extra content into
our HTML for the sole purpose of layouts
which goes against everything we've
learned about how to markup websites
this is also layouts today this is how
we have to do things well it is today
that you're going to change all this
just before I get into it consider what
the web looks like right now
this is bootstrap the official
documentation telling you how to make a
layout that has two columns look at the
HTML look how many nested divs are
necessary to get this to work this is a
wordpress theme builder plus a some sort
of page layouts plugin I can tell you by
looking at this HTML all of this stuff
generates a box
with some content in it but it's
necessary because we have to do all this
floating and clearing and nesting and
nesting and nesting and nesting
underscores this the same in this
slightly less extreme version when you
look at the overall markup of
underscores there's a bunch of elements
within underscores that are there solely
for the purpose of layout so the blue
boxes here are the header the main the
aside and the footer the red boxes are
there for layout purposes so whatever we
could take all that extra craft away
have just the semantic markup and
nothing else and then solve the layout
problems in CSS in a clean and simple
way instead of this layout we have this
which is easier to read makes way more
sense what if we didn't have to do all
this crazy stuff anymore if you look at
my example the blue items are the ones
that matter the red don't but even if I
take away the red items the structure of
this document still makes no sense we
have a heading 1 then we have a main
then we have a header then we have an
aside and then we have a footer if I
take all the extra craft away and
reorganize the document all of a sudden
it makes much more sense from a semantic
standpoint header h1 main beside footer
the problem is up until this point all
our layout tools have been content out
and one-dimensional meaning you apply a
layout to an individual item and then
you have to relate that item to other
things what we need is a two dimensional
layout that works layout in and that's
what CSS grid gives us so instead of
doing all the boxing thing I was talking
about before what if we start by saying
here's what we want let's apply a grid
to it just like you would do in design
draw great on top and then you say we're
going to place contents on this grid do
you have your semantic markup then you
simply grab each item the header the h1
the main the sidebar and the footer and
you place them on the document that
makes sense all of a sudden you don't
last thing with the guy with the blinds
that everyone shares on the internet all
the time
that's it'll be like old applies work
too bad this works perfectly go to code
pen this example is a live website
although screen grabs are from the
website all the content restructures the
way suppose to you can play around with
it you can see exactly what's going on
and the craziest part is when you read
the code you'll be like I understand
what's happening here I don't even need
to understand CSS grid I can actually
see how this works so others are working
I've been told that listening to my
talks to be a bit like trying to capture
a firehose sometimes so I've decided to
try to structure this in such a way that
it's more like strapping fire hoses on a
platform and then flying all right but
ever but this means I need your absolute
attention I'm going to crash through
some stuff here it'll be nice and quick
ok so brace yourself
stand firm CSS grid needs new
terminology so we have grid container
grade item grid line grid cell good
track grid area grid gap I apologize I
know you have to do this but it's the
simultaneous translator or does not
appreciate these 55 so a grid container
is any container in your document that
you create a grid inside you do that by
simply declaring display grid you can do
this to as many elements as you want on
the page it doesn't out it does not
matter a grid item is any direct
descendant of a grid container
so if you create a grid any direct
descendant automatically becomes a grid
item that's placed inside the grid but
only the first level descendant just
like it is with flexbox a grid line is
any of the lines you draw inside the
grid horizontal or vertical the grid
lines are numbered by default so the
first edge of the grid either vertical
horizontal has the line number 1 and
then you just count them 2 3 4 5 6 and
the last one has the last number the
grid cell is any cell inside the grid a
grid area is any defined rectangular
area inside the grid that covers more
than one cell a grid track is either a
horizontal track or a vertical track so
a row or a column and a great gap is the
space between each of the cells if you
choose to add basically gutters got that
good don't worry these slides are online
you can go look at them later and this
will become part of your vocabulary
anyway so CSS grid in a nutshell how
does this actually work how do we apply
it today number one define a grid on an
element where you want agreed to appear
number two place items within that grid
where you want them to appear number
three make world peace that's all there
is to it
what does it look like well here's my
example this is the semantic markup with
know CSS apply except for color then we
start by grabbing just the site
container that's the container that
wraps everything and we declare display
grid so now we have a grid then we
decide how many columns and how many
rows we want let me do that using grid
template columns and grid template rows
and here what we do is say the distance
from the edge of the grid to the first
line that's the first value then the
distance to the next one it's the next
value and so on and so on so you're
declaring the width between each of the
lines and then another line is drawn
this comes with new features like the fr
or fraction
value that allows you to say take one
fraction of the available space and then
put a line there so you can make truly
dynamic layout
do the same with rose you just declare a
list where you want the rose appear and
they will appear automatically once
you've drawn lower growth you have cells
and your browser automatically places
all the direct descendants of the grid
element in those cells from the top left
to the bottom right then for each
individual element you can if you want
to declare a grid column and a grid row
property and say I want this element to
appear from column line 2 to column line
4 and from row line 2 to row line 3 that
means you literally find column line 2
and column line 4 and you put the
content in between those two lines
same with rows well here you see what
I'm talking about we're doing layout in
so we create the layout first let me
just dump content where we want them to
appear when you look at this you realize
there are all these new things you can
do like for instance create actual white
space on a layout you can just choose
not to populate cells then you have
white space no space or gifs or anything
like that anymore I want you to know
this you can then place any of your
elements anywhere you want in the grid
looks promising right but you have to do
all this counting stuff I keep track of
the line numbers and then what if it's
response we're going to keep changing
the greater it gets kind of nuts in my
layout I move elements particularly the
header and the footer
keeping track alive with numbers would
be a pain and to be fair you can
actually give each of the track lines a
name and refer to them by name instead
of my number but that's still quite a
lot of stuff to deal with so we have
this new property called grid template
areas a grid template area is nuts it's
almost like a ski you declare grid
template area
and then you write out each of the cells
in your grid and you say what is the
name of this cell so for instance here I
have the three cells at the top our
title title title and then we have main
header header and main sidebar footer
then you use the grid area property on
individual child items and you just
declare the name of the area you want
that element to appear so if you say
grid area header well that's wrong
that's right if you say grid area header
the element goes to the header area if
you say grid area title it goes to the
title area and this allows us to do
crazy responsive web design because that
means instead of doing a bunch of crazy
stuff all you have to do is change the
grid template areas and then the item so
you've already said this is going in the
title area this is going in the header
area we'll just move around the grid so
your responsive code and your media
queries become very very simple and
anyone who reads this code can see okay
so we have a grid that has two columns
and then we put the title and title and
minun header and main a sidebar and then
when the screen gets wider we have three
columns and here we have title title
title main header header the CSS
actually visibly declares what's going
on no more no more everything just works
this is that point where your brain will
start going like what is happening this
is business this doesn't actually
compute yet and trust me I've been
working with this for over a year every
time I sit down and do a new grid layout
my brain keeps telling me to do things
the old way and I have to keep throwing
my brain out and then replacing it with
a new one which means my kid is walking
around the background layer making
noises when
he grows up he won't think the way I do
and he'll be like this is super simple
and then I'll tell them about flows and
clearly we go like why would you do it
like that that's so crazy there's also
this weird little thing called nested
grids now in the original grid
specification from a couple of years ago
you have the ability to create a grid
and then have an element within the grid
inherit the grid so you would get
consistency that never happened in
browsers so instead what we do is we
declare multiple grids inside one
another and it turns out that's actually
a huge benefit because then you can say
I have an overall layout grid right
layout my header my footer my sidebar
and so on
then you can have a sub grid just for
the main content layout and you can even
have a grid inside that grid for
something else and you have detailed
control over every single component
within your layout and as you know the
new trend in web design is to work on
component level well let's the grids
allow you to literally work on component
level and this means for example if
you're making a WordPress theme you can
make individual content grids for
individual types of content so if you
apply a certain class to any elements
then you can change the grid completely
using pure CSS no more fancy templates
and crazy PHP just use CSS but older
browsers this is the absolute biggest
argument against CSS grid first of all
all modern browsers support CSS grid now
every single one of them there's an
issue but I'll get to that in a second
before we get to that there's also the
question of I think it's too soon
this is emerging technology it's not
mature yet true it's emerging technology
but you know small websites like the New
York Times have them started using them
so I'd say any client that says we're
not ready for this yet because no one is
using it it can be urged forward this is
something we can do today
but there are two elephants in the room
right do you how these see you give me
way too much credit
they're always these things that don't
work the way we want to so we have
Internet Explorer 10 and 11 and we have
edge who are not currently following the
spec exactly point of order if it wasn't
for Internet Explorer 10 we wouldn't
have CSS grid CSS grid was invented for
Internet Explorer 10 and the reason why
these two browsers are lagging behind is
because the other browsers decided to
change the spec but the spec is built
into Windows so Microsoft has to update
all of their operating systems to get
this to catch on however edge is
probably a couple of weeks away from
getting full grid support and I'll show
you how to create proper backwards
compatibility for all other browsers
there's this other thing that has
nothing they would CSS grid that's
called a feature query that we can use
now to ask the browser do you support
this grid problem with this CSS property
and we can use that to test whether or
not the browser support grid the
canonical best practice is to ask app
supports display grid works exactly like
a media query so if it says yes and we
run the code inside the problem is edge
does support grid it is to sports the
wrong spec so if you're testing for grid
support and edge test for something that
edge does not support within the grid
spec for example grid area auto then
edge won't try to run the grid my
recommendation here is actually to serve
up the mobile experience on all browsers
that don't support grid and this is
where people fall off the horse right
this is like wait wait wait wait wait
what so that means the site will look
the same in all browsers
that's exactly right the thing is we've
been doing responsive web design for 10
years now no we have not we've been
doing responsive web design since 2010
and that we've established an entire
language around not serving up the same
experience across all browsers because
on a mobile browser the website looks
totally different from what it does on a
large desktop browser there is no actual
reason why a website should look the
same across all browsers except that we
keep saying they should so we can change
our methodology around this making
everything look the same across all
browsers is a bad habit we should be
making things look the best they can on
whatever browsers are supported in
responsive web design allows us to do
this we just need to migrate it from not
just saying responsive web design it's
about the width of the screen to also
say we can make it responsive to the age
of the browser accessible mobile first
layout work well on all browsers if you
don't believe me go look at the mobile
version of Wikipedia on your desktop
browser you will never use regular
Wikipedia again the mobile version on
the desktop browser is so much better I
don't understand why they just don't
move forward this is progressive
enhancement this is our responsibility
we progressively enhance the web because
if we don't then we'll get stuck in the
past forever so practical approach to
CSS grid right now so you can use it
when you walk out of this room first
build accessible mobile first layouts
without grid that is your baseline so
make it work on a mobile phone make it
sure that it still works when it's on a
wide screen then use that mobile first
layout as the fallback so if everything
goes to hell mobile first works then use
add support to the text grid support at
the appropriate breakpoint when
everything starts looking weird add a
grid then keep scaling up the width of
the screen add another grid
at another grid on another grid because
people have screens that are this wide
right now so you need to account for
that so don't believe me go to my
brother's house he has this ridiculously
huge screen so remember the layout I
drew that was impossible see you apply
grid to it it's not only impossible it's
something that makes sense and just
works and it's the layout that's then
the new theme on my website and you can
go check it out on github and put it on
your own site as well your path to CSS
grid starts here today right now number
one use Firefox when you develop because
Firefox has a grid inspector so anytime
you find an element that has grid on it
there's a little hashtag type thing
that's supposed to look like a grid and
if you click on that and the inspector
the gridlines appear in your browser you
can actually see the grid while you're
working with it I'm sure the other
browsers will catch up but right now
Firefox has it second Rachel andrew has
a website called grid by example this is
basically doctoring rachel andrew is by
and large the reason why we have CSS
grid and browsers today she's been
pushing it for years and years and years
and she's documented absolutely
everything so you want to know how it
works go to grid by example Mozilla
developer Network has tons of
documentation most of it written by
either Rachel Andrew or Jenn Simmons it
is a great resource it's documented
every single property and everything
that's going on CSS tricks has a
complete guide to CSS grid which is just
like the complete guide to flexbox which
is also the same content over again [ __ ]
Miami scene which is running on my web
site is on github and you can go check
it out pick it apart
send pull requests complain about the
lack of internationalization what you'll
notice is CSS grid respect text
direction so there is no RTL see a style
sheet because wood CSS grid you don't
need it anymore
I wrote an article about this that came
out in Smashing Magazine yesterday
called the building production-ready CSS
quit layout
today that covers what I talked about
here plus how I designed the scene plus
a bunch of other stuff go read it go
where you want to go where you want the
web to go and the rest will follow we in
this room control a large percentage of
the web and if wheel adopts CSS quit now
and do it properly the web will follow
don't believe me this is the LinkedIn
office in Carpinteria that I go through
occasionally they built a new building
and now they put this huge patch of
grass directly in front of the entrance
so if you look at the image here there's
a building here so everyone walks like
this and I sold a patch of grass so this
is taken on the first day and I'm like
this is insane
whoever designed this was not thinking
about the end user so I just started
walking across the grass and I was
walking across the grass for a couple
hours to make a pass and then a couple
of months later someone sent me this
picture and then their code a week ago
someone sent me this picture
if you paved cow paths meaning walk
where you want everything's ahead
eventually someone put paving stones
down so designers in the room CSS grid
means you can finally use proper grid
systems in your design there also means
design the browser is now really easy
same developers start using CSS grid
today in all your work even if it means
providing full fallback for everything
you do I have links for that if you want
to talk to me later framework people CSS
grid cures your dividers so you should
take a strong inoculation right now page
builders this is make or break time CSS
grid plus Guttenberg and WordPress means
that most of what page builders does
will be handled inside WordPress itself
so if you're building a page builder you
need to get on top of the spec and
figure out how it fits into your
our business model set best practices be
responsible because CSS grid allows you
to mess around with the structure order
of your content and can make sites
really inaccessible so don't do that but
use it for good build the web you want
to see and repeat after me
make it accessible make it fancy and
make sure the fancy doesn't break
accessibility oh come on
stand up everyone of you stand up come
on everyone of you stand up this is your
mantra all right number one what number
two number three
thank you very much
[Applause]